nous parlons ici d'une étude qui a été
présentée en préprint c'est-à-dire qu'il
n'est pas encore accepté par des revues
scientifiques heureusement devrais-je
dire qui porte 30 000 patients qui ont
été traités à l'Institut hospitalo
universitaire Marseille Méditerranée
pour dire les mots en dehors de tout
cadre d'expérimentation clinique en
dehors de tout cadre d'utilisation des
médicaments puisqu'ils étaient utilisés
hors
naam autorisation de mise sur le marché
alors concernant cette cette institut en
plus médicament je tiens à le préciser
qui avait déjà fait la preuve de leur
inefficacité dans le cadre du traitement
de la covid-19
par rapport à cette situation une
enquête
IGAS igesr nous a rendu ses conclusions
en septembre 2022 à ma collègue Sylvie
retaillot et moi-même nous avons
immédiatement saisi le procureur de la
République de Marseille par le biais de
deux articles 40 devant la constatation
dans cette enquête de pratique aussi
bien managériale que de suivi des études
cliniques
inappropriée voir des viandes nous avons
dans les suites convoquées l'ensemble
des administrateurs de cette i hachu en
leur imposant la mise en place d'un plan
de redressement sur la base des
conclusions de cette enquête
IGAS igesr comme vous je déplore ce
nouvel épisode
inadmissible de cette affaire sachant
que la justice est en est en train de
suivre son cours comme vous avez pu le
constater avec moi dès ce matin devant
cette publication qui pourrait cette
proposition de publication qui pour moi
s'apparente a de la provocation nous
serons amenés et l'étude est en cours
avec les services juridiques apprendre
avec ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau pour
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
et moi-même toutes les mesures
nécessaires envers l'ensemble des
signatures de cet article
[Musique]